for honor the game which allows biking
nice and samurai to fight to the death
is here but which side are you going to
take we've already looked at the samurai
and how they go about killing by kings
and knights but now it's time to look at
the knife and they're attacking prowess
we have four characters and eight
executions to look at so let's start
first up for the night is the warden
these guys and gals are perfectly
balanced in both defense and attack said
to be dedicated to defending the lands
the wardens use a long sword which has
excellent reach and their heavy chain
mail absorbs most attacks they have an
unblockable shoulder attack which will
get you out of trouble often and have an
adaptive fighting style which can be
picked up and played instantly this is a
great character to start out with the
blade on the side may be used most of
the time but the pommel on the other
side is just as pious just ask these
opponents
next up are the conquerors who forgot a
long shot in pairs of a shield and flail
these chaps were seen as fodder and were
sent out to die but those who survived
its or through utilizing defense and
timing attacks to perfection they have
an auto block function to help you out
but it will take time to master this
character class but when you do expect
to use your flail to chalk out one
opponent or even AB literate their
school completely the peacekeepers are
the sound assassins of the battlefield
and utilize ultra fast attacks and
short-range merely their mobility allows
them to quickly attack and run away
while they still can and really that
catches bigger enemy not guard with
factious you can dual wield a sword and
knife and make your enemies of pin
cushion
finally the LA bringers these guys are
the heavyweights of the night team they
use an eight-foot sphere ax combination
simply known as a poor luck how's the
name suggests they are here to make sure
everyone is aware of the laws of the
land and they have the armor and the
skill to back it up so that's the night
are you joining them or do you prefer
Vikings or samurai let us know in the
comments below I'm team samurai please
do the favorite drop of the like and
think about subscribing i'm adam from
playstation grenade and i'll see you on
the battlefield
[Music]